bonjour qu'il ya c'est curieux comme
vous pouvez le voir je ne suis pas au
studio mais chez moi
confinés comme beaucoup d'entre nous en
cette période et mes pensées vont
particulièrement à ceux qui n'ont pas le
privilège de pouvoir travailler depuis
chez eux ni même d'avoir un chez eux
tout court est aussi tout
particulièrement aux soignants et à
toutes celles et ceux qui luttent en ce
moment même contre la maladie
donc dans ce contexte un peu particulier
je vous présente une version un peu plus
légères dst de science fait un peu avec
les moyens du bord donc nous allons
prendre juste quelques minutes pour
parler de sciences nous évader un peu et
puis nourrir notre curiosité
alors c'est parti à me baladant sur la
chaîne youtube du sénat j'ai trouvé ça
ils sont trop mignons ces petits
écureuils canadiens ne sont pas
seulement très mignon et femmes de
beurre de cacahuètes mais ça on n'y
reviendra plus tard il nous en
apprennent beaucoup sur les effets des
l'environnement social et en particulier
sur le stress qu'il peut provoquer bon
je vous explique alors déjà ces petits
écureuils terrestre s'appelle des sperme
au fils parce qu'il mange des graines il
hiberne et la colonie étudié par les
soins de suite de strasbourg est
installé dans le parc provincial de chip
river en alberta au canada depuis 27 ans
des scientifiques sur ces animaux tout
au long de cette saison de reproduction
et comptabilise méthodiquement agression
et coopération entre les individus et
ils ont montré que les femelles sont
moins agressive envers leurs proches
parentes meilleurs finisseurs qu envers
des individus d'autres familles avec une
petite subtilité si les femelles proches
sont plus âgés est dominante
il y encore beaucoup d'agressions ce qui
veut dire qu'en gros si cette amère ça
marche pas très bien
afin de mieux comprendre les effets de
cet environnement social sur l'organisme
les scientifiques effectue aussi des
prélèvements d'adn de sang et de crottes
en attirant l'espère maufils avec du
beurre de cacahuète et je les comprends
leur but comparer le taux de stress de
l'organisme à la composition de
l'environnement social et aux données
comportementales de terrain pour cela en
connaissons l'identité de tous les
individus de la communauté les
chercheurs réalisent une poêle sociale
une représentation visuelle de tous les
liens sociaux de la colonie et il
retrouve que s'installer proches
d'individus apparentés réduit le stress
sauf peut-être quand on est à côté de sa
mère prochaine étape montrer comment ces
différents niveaux de stress impact le
développement des jeunes et se
transmettre aux générations suivantes
et comme certains mécanismes liés au
stress sont similaires chez les
mammifères humains et non humains
voilà un projet de recherche qui
pourrait nous en apprendre beaucoup sur
nous mêmes c'est tout pour ce mini veste
vous pouvez retrouver plus d'image de
ces créatures si mignonne ainsi que la
méthodologie de cette étude dans le
reportage sur la chaîne du cnrs je vous
dis bon courage à bientôt n'oubliez pas
de mettre un pouce bleus de partager et
de vous abonner